[Music]
so haley joel osment you guys remember
him yeah so that's the kid from
six success that's wrong no no no six
months from the sixth day success short
sneaker movie
over
he does the same with where the cabinets
open and then his palms are sweaty knees
weak arms are heavy he's very good
that's wonderful this vomit sweater
already mom sweetie
i got you so no um haley joel says that
he has the highest admiration for his
sixth seventh uh sixth sense co-star
bruce willis highest admiration okay
i mean bruce willis
he's done a lot of [ __ ] because bruce
willis's family just shared a statement
posted to instagram from demi moore on
wednesday that detailed the actor's
struggle
with aphasia which has led to his forced
retirement what is that so it's like you
have cognitive disabilities like you
can't say things quite right and so
you can't just sit there and bruce
willis has this yeah he's like you got
your mother father but you know what
that's the that's the freaking uh
censored version for abc but if it's tnt
yeah if stallone could do it though
you think anybody could do it would
think why does stallone have something
so he has like [ __ ] mr pawsy he's
been punched around somebody he's a
punch drunk he mr pulse
yeah it's a new variation well dude he
was doing it for real though like
respect for him he was taking shots all
kind of all kinds and he's probably
swinging his head even more you know
making his brain rattle in the skull
yeah and then they did eye the tiger he
was like god damn like my brain is not
used to this kind of rhythm because his
brain was used to doing like the normal
thing which was like
the rocky theme but then
once the eye of the tiger was just
different yeah so we couldn't handle it
you had to pick it up in intensity a
little bit exactly haley joel reacted on
instagram posting a picture of bruce
owen with the caption it's been
difficult to find the right words for
someone i've always looked up to
first on the big screen and then by some
wild stroke of luck in person which is
decent
commentary because you said stroke
he says he's a true legend who has
enriched all of our lives with a
singular career that spans nearly half a
century i'm so grateful for what i got
to witness firsthand and for the
enormous body of work he built he built
for us to enjoy for years and years to
come
and what a stroker he was there's no
[ __ ] you denied that's what he said
and so he said he gave a heart stroke
what a stroke a long stroke haley draws
him is a little weird you know what i
mean
he's a little weird he's a weird choice
of words yeah really was he married to
demi moore yeah oh okay but that means
like they're divorced huh are they
divorced okay because ashton kutcher was
with that right he swooped kitchen
ashton kutzman
um left demi moore pitchman or cushman
no ashton
cushman
so he was with demi moore for a while
but then he left but like he was part of
the willis family there was like estate
more family the kutchman bunch exactly
and then he actually ended up being like
hey um sorry i'm leaving for milo kunas
because they're on the 70s show together
and they don't want to watch their kids
that's right
and so he fell for her big time and he's
like dude my wife has some weird knees
so he left demi moore at the time and he
left her for mila kunas who has way
better needs he wanted demi less yes
exactly thank you somebody gets it but i
don't get i don't really get the joke of
that but i but he did one or less hey
you're just a messenger so then um so um
m knight
m sham shyamalan says
i just wanted to express the respect and
deep admiration i have for bruce and his
family as they move forward with the
courage and high spirits that will
always have to find them you know um now
i know why people uh after this came out
people say would you talk about willis
because he can't speak anymore so then
they don't understand and they're like
what you're talking about willis
it's bruce willis the whole time they're
donald broods and m knight was like you
know he's pretty hardcore we all know
like am night shyamalan am shamsham alam
stands by his movies but he was like man
i always thought you'd go out
like under a pool cover
so that's what he tweeted wow you mean
it was a joke
a pool oh like drowning you know he's
talking about like unbreakable where his
weakness was like drowning
so he wasn't being serious but like we
all know like fans now but yeah most
people are like well it's really [ __ ]
up actually but okay i thought he would
be on elite meteor other than die hard
with the vengeance yeah what was your
favorite favorite bruce with uh
six monkeys bro armageddon sex monkeys
dude i enjoyed armageddon armageddon all
the way i love armageddon i never
watched that one really oh man
what a surprise
i like them in tears of the sun i liked
him in the love guru with uh
stupid you're not wrong yeah dude four
monkeys was a [ __ ] good movie though
how could the monkeys disappear you have
to watch the movie just said six
four of them now that was the prequel
ketchup bart catch up and not to spoil
anything i don't want to play anything
but by the end of movies not many
monkeys oh yeah i like smiles of the sun
smiles on the sun yeah
take check that out
[Laughter]
i will i'll look for an emoji on the on
what platform is that on on
zulu netflix
oh yeah i've seen that
you have flexi from the insurance
company but low key though die hard with
a vengeance bro it's so good
when he's walking down the street with a
sign and that whole scene it's so good
is that the first flat one no no that's
the third one yeah with samuel
remember the nakamishi corporation it
was like you got to put four gallons in
the five gallon bottle so you take the
three guys and then then you have two
seconds
the second one's sick too because it
opens with the [ __ ] with um with that
cat who's like naked and he's like
[ __ ] fighting with the screen but
there's nothing there yeah and he's like
he's like completely naked and he's like
like
no no no the best part is like they're
basically you know they're like hey alan
mcmahon the first movie he's a [ __ ]
he's like this guy fights naked from the
tv what are you gonna do with bruce
willis
ellen rickman you think if about you're
here you're like i think bruce willis is
[ __ ] in this movie alan rickman has a
milk voice
you know what that is like when you
drink a little bit of milk and then the
the lactose kind of gets in the stuck
your throat a little bit cigarettes
yeah a little flammy and then it changes
and i miss alan richmond me too that's
what he sounds rest in peace i started
to get this weird feeling when i watch
like nostalgic movies i get sad and i
don't watch it anymore because i i miss
the era the whole world like i miss like
the 90s like i miss like doing all the
things tied to that memory of like
watching die hard and then we go to
[ __ ] pizza hut yeah and then the
pizza isn't [ __ ] there and then i'm
just like oh my god i'm having a
meltdown because i can't go to pizza and
have a birthday party there and there's
real action
real real action in movies you know when
like they had huge budgets they actually
blew up planes and stuff like that in
movies practical action i just missed
the time i missed how he saw the world
back then but it was practical
everything we didn't know yet like like
alan rickman would sit there and he
would do some ravenclaw [ __ ] but
everyone called him the slytherin
and so that was all practical effects
like everyone didn't know yeah until
later on everyone's like oh he's a
slytherin but like everyone's like no
he's a ravenclaw
everyone what about bruce willis and um
pulp fiction oh that's a good bruce
lewis that's right
being raised being [ __ ] yeah being
reigns being civil [ __ ] yeah
crichton collection yeah so good but but
his his uh character didn't uh have as
much range i think in uh pulp
that's the closest range you could be
exactly what i thought and he was with
like some french chick-fil-a
that's range i was like this is in
widescreen double bars this is a sick
try to get butt [ __ ] as hard as
anybody ever been [ __ ] on tv and
they showed it a lot too they showed a
good amount of it who got buffalo bingo
the guy from mission impossible in
[ __ ] pulp fiction
oh it's because of the guy that that
pulled them in and trapped
baby peter green okay
i just i'm my memory all the esoteric
people i'm sorry
i just remember the uma thurman dancing
here's the bad guy and dumb and dumb so
many memories i do still like armageddon
i'm not gonna lie guys i told you
[ __ ] armageddon is the best
that's your favorite one it's all about
deep impact dude
deep impact was fun though morgan
freeman
dude you put elijah wood on a bike
and you're like this guy could outrace
any [ __ ] meteor head to earth
armageddon was better than the deep
impact though i'm just throwing that you
know they bring back old school movies
right what if they brought a bruce mil
bruce willis movie that's like die hard
or something and they remake it do you
think they can remake that do you think
it can be done no it's unnecessary what
about fifth element what about oh that's
bro the last the last scene where he has
the match yeah oh so good you guys
remember that scene yeah of course i got
so sad when the singer got shot
spoiler blind huh
[Laughter]
then she's still alive apparently on
star wars galactic cruiser or whatever
the [ __ ] feel that much it's all gucci
but no um so you ever watched mercury
rising yeah mercury rising is good too i
don't remember that bruce willis movie
too as well bruce willis classic shout
out
you know what's the end of an error you
know which one sucked
the one where he uh uh is a looper oh
looper you didn't like that wait it was
great
i didn't like it i loved that movie love
it maybe i need to watch it again maybe
i wasn't in the right health space maybe
you didn't have enough iq or something
yeah you don't understand sci-fi and
time-warping you are a dancer it's not
even your own brain's fault do you guys
remember the movies look who's talking
oh yeah
didn't even know he was in that did you
know did you know that he's in beefs and
butthead do america nowhere no is he the
voice of someone yeah he's the main bad
guy in that hey do you guys remember
when he was in uh that parody movie
i can't remember what's up man but
remember when um oh he's in one of the
oceans too when he goes um oh julia
robertson's girl
yeah yeah ocean's like music hey julia
and she's like what the [ __ ] bruce yeah
oh when she's pretending not to be julia
yeah but he was also in like one of the
it was like a hot chocolate movie or
something like that but he was he so
if you remember
a helicopter comes and shoots up a
trailer and it was like a joke about
lethal weapon too
yeah and then bruce willis he's john
mcclane in that john mcclane in that
scene with the white beater and then
he's like he's like hey what the [ __ ]
you got the wrong trailer and then like
oh we're sorry we're sorry that guy's
like with the machine gun and he said
we're so sorry
no problem
no problem
[Laughter]
that's great i love bruce that's a good
bit that's the only time he's john
mcclane not in a diehard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you